families throughout history have been
chosen to make this decision your family
must choose to willingly sacrifice one
of the three of you to prevent the
apocalypse we're not sacrificing anyone
for every no you give us hundreds of
thousands of people are going to die I
got a two-parter I'm working with night
fur so I know that you reached out to
him to get this role going into the
shoot what is something about him that
you were really excited to experience
getting to work together but then also
having come out of it what's something
he brought out in you as a performer
that you never could have expected well
what he brought out with me um I have to
start with that because immediately the
answer pops it in my head
but what uh he brought out in me is
um a way to kind of to juggle emotions
to balance emotions to and sometimes
even hide emotions and cover them with
other emotions which is something I've
never been asked to do so I wasn't no I
didn't know if I was capable of doing it
uh and still when I
attempted to do it was unsure if it
worked but he always assured me that it
was exactly what he was looking for and
I would always say if you're happy I'm
happy but
um what I mean by that was sometimes
when I was going through these scenes
and I was feeling a certain way and I
was performing them that way
he would say you're correct in the way
you should be feeling but you have to
remember that Leonard he always feels
the pressure of being in charge he has
to even if he's feeling a certain way
he has to appear that he's just keeping
it cool he's all together he's in charge
he is guidance and so I was feeling one
way but trying to perform another way
and I was very unsure whether I was
doing it correctly but um I I hope that
it worked and and uh anyway he was happy
I was happy great success in that
perspective I truly mean it not just
because I'm sitting here talking to you
that's making me think so sometimes you
doubted yourself on set all the time
what was I guess Knight's monitor dance
like something he would do behind the
monitor that would signal to you he
really liked to take well that was the
thing because there are certain there
are certain directors when you know when
they're happy like Denise I know and
Disney is happy he comes out and he says
I deeply love this I deeply love this
and uh with night night's a very
monotone person he's very even keeled
and so you never really should you're
never really sure but every once in a
while I was like I'd get I'd get this
from him I was like
are you sure you got an eagle
bro
and I knew when he called me bro that he
was happy with something that makes me
so happy I love that so this is a very
different type of role for you and you
deserve many more in this particular
category I think we were talking about
it with army of the Dead the end of that
movie in particular I saw that and I'm
like you could do anything well beyond
the box that you know frankly this
industry has put you in but given that
it was making me think is there any past
onset experience or particular role that
you were surprised to find coming in
handy here when playing someone like
Leonard not necessarily roll you know I
always draw for my life experiences
but I can't think of any particular role
that I really Drew from for this but I I
draw from certain you know moments in my
life and definitely pick up emotions
through that
um but this was just something so unique
and something that I had never done
before which is why I sought after this
role and these types of roles even you
brought upon me the dead I mean
originally I had no interest in doing
that film
but uh Zack Snyder said that he would
give me the opportunity to kind of make
this character more layered and not so
one noted and give him a heart and make
this relationship between him and his
daughter you know a little more invested
in us so that was why I signed on to
Army of the dead because there were
those moments
um but this is the type of role and I
that I've sought out all these years to
really kind of
stretch myself as a performer but also
you know open people's eyes to who I
wanted to be as an actor and not because
I've said all along that I I don't want
to be a movie star I want to be a good
actor and so this was kind of the role
that validated that statement I heard
you say that quite a few times and it's
just like it genuinely fills my heart to
see you doing that and showing people
that you were right and you can do it I
wanted to refer to one quote that I read
of knights he said about you right guy
right role right moment in his life do
you agree with that could you have done
something like this sooner or did now
feel like the perfect time to play a
character like Leonard I don't know if I
could have done it sooner I can't say
for sure that I couldn't have
but I uh
I definitely can say that there's no way
that sooner in my career
would my name have lent enough value to
lead this film because it's a big film
for a big director with a big cast and
I've been building myself all these
years and and mostly through supporting
roles
so I can say that that I wouldn't been
ready emotionally you know I may have
but I just can't say for sure because
even when I was on this film I just
doubted myself so much even now watching
the film I've only seen it once but I
completely picked myself apart and I can
see where I think there were things that
I wasn't happy with but I I hope that
that's a good thing
excuse me meaning that I'm never really
satisfied and I want to grow as an actor
I see room for improvement and I hope
that just expresses how passionate I am
about this this craft a thing to have in
this field or any field for that matter
when you doubt yourself is an ability to
kind of process that but also Forge
forward so when you come home from a day
on set where you doubted yourself how do
you move into the next day and kind of
push that aside
um you know what well luckily with this
film we didn't have a whole lot of room
to process
it was such a hard schedule it was long
long days and since I you know I started
on this film they started this film
without me because I was in Guardians so
I literally had two days between rapping
on Guardians and going into this film so
I didn't have really a lot of time to
process anything
it was kind of after the fact that I
started to put it all together and
really you know think back and when I
saw the film was really
it kind of started to kind of cringe and
I wish I had done this and wish I had
more been more prepared for that but I
think that I do that with every role no
matter even if they're smaller roles
even if they're the smallest roles I'm
always going to be that person to be
fair I do this with every single
interview and I feel like if I lose that
it means I don't care enough and so I
never want to lose that and I that's a
good thing I think I think it's a good
thing because it means we just want to
just be better we just we have room to
grow we still love what we're doing
enough to care about you know being good
at it I would not agree more I'm happy
to be in good company on that idea so
you brought up Marvel and I know that
you said you're ready to move on and you
were just talking about growing as an
actor too what is a particular acting
muscle that maybe marble hasn't given
you the opportunity to flex that you're
really eager to explore in a future
project I think there were a bit you
know bits and pieces of where I got to
you know kind of express myself
completely as a performer I mean
definitely there was elements that were
left out with the character because I
was somewhat limited but what I was
really kind of disappointed in
uh was I just felt like the character
was really much more interesting
um
but then given credit for because he had
such a great such a tragic background
story but at the same time I always
understood that um I was a supporting
character and um they had their slate of
where they were going with certain
things and uh you know anything they
weren't really and there wasn't
necessary to step away from that formula
um but I think that was it more than
anything I just felt like there was so
much left on the table for that
character so much more to explore
but I just um you know people I think a
lot of times don't really see they think
of Drax they think of the character and
they think Guardians of the Galaxy and
they don't really realize that I did
seven films as that character over 10
years
um so is it it's a very Bittersweet
thing because that
character that role um that franchise
changed my life not just my career but
it changed my life
so it's hard letting go but at the same
time
it's it's been 10 years and I still have
places I want to go as a performer so I
I have to let go and like all you know
all things must end and uh so very
bittersweet because I love everybody
involved in those projects and I'm not
just saying that because that's what
typically what people say but I did they
just when we started that out together
it wasn't a massive hit it was something
that we were hoping we were crossing our
fingers would be but we knew it was
special because we were in the room we
were connecting with each other
and there were you know when you think
back to you know Chris Pratt then Chris
Pratt wasn't a massive movie star then
you know he was hoping to be but he
wasn't we went out to the movies and Saw
movies together he can't do that now so
we just started in a different place and
ended up in a different place but that's
why they're just they're special they're
special moments to me they're they're
life-changing moments so it's hard to
let those moments go again not just
saying this because I'm sitting here
Drax is my favorite character in the MCU
and that complexity that you just
highlighted in him is what draws me to
him thank you all right we have a little
game because there is a holiday coming
up where some people need to express
hard news to someone else and in this
movie Leonard has to warmly and kindly
and in a convincing way tell people bad
news so for Valentine's Day if someone
out there needs help breaking up with
someone I have some cliche breakup lines
here okay can you read them as Leonard
okay
as you do that I will say your tone as
Leonard could not be better could not be
better
and I think we should see different
people
okay
[Music]
foreign
I'm really sorry
and it's
it's not you
it's me
[Laughter]
thank you thank you
I wish I wish I had a night to study
that dialogue I would come here tomorrow
Crush that
it's really happening sweetheart close
your eyes
will you make a choice first I want to
ask you about Dave because Dave is often
boxed into a certain type of role
Leonard is not that type of role so what
are you most looking forward to other
directors out there getting to
experience if they give Dave the
opportunity to break out of that box
like you did well you know it was
interesting as you were saying that I
was thinking back to what I was
considering I was considering this
there is one person in the world that
could pull this off and be a giant and
do 30 pages of monologue maybe right he
hasn't done it but that was my instinct
there maybe or I could let go of the
whole giant part and just open it up to
every other actor in the world the
really world-class actors you know all
the ones Academy Award guys all of that
stuff I can then pursue one of them and
have them do the 30 pages of monologue
right and I was like what should I do
and then I went
my heart was like God
it's Dave and I was just like send Dave
the script I don't blame you your
instincts in that respect were spot on
is there even though you had that faith
in him is there anything he did in the
role that caught even You by surprise
where you didn't even know he was
capable of that you know we started to
rehearse I rehearsed like a play and and
that's not you know what the history of
the movies that he's been in and I think
it's a rare thing anyway to to rehearse
that's what they you know the other
actors say wow you actually Force us to
come and live together and work and and
rehearse and I think he's you know was
worried that these were all such amazing
actors and all this stuff and and as he
just started to let go a little bit and
rehearsals I started to go wait that
what you just did there and then I was
like that was amazing and then I would
call him after rehearsals and he was
like I know you know I'm sorry I mean be
apologizing and all this stuff and I'd
be like Dave
I know you think I'm I'm bsing you but
there was some real magic that you're
doing I mean real magic and then we'd
rehearse and rehearse and then when we
got to the stage and we got to the
actual day the actors I think were a
little you know he's a giant like 320
pound giant comes on the satin and then
I go action and then he starts and it's
like a 10 like he's at a 10 and every I
remember seeing the other actors faces
they were like looking at each other
like
whoa and I I felt this before and it's
happened to me so many times with Haley
James McAvoy where the rumor just goes
you know the electricity shoots and
you're going wow we're seeing seeing
something incredibly special right now
meanwhile dude still doubting himself
over there I'm like I saw the movie you
are great but you literally do not have
a thing to worry about never he's never
gonna listen to you I can tell I'm like
that too I get it I wanted to ask you a
little bit about the rating because you
have the R rating here but I think the
movie is far less graphic than the book
so what is it like figuring out how much
to show and when showing something is
just not necessary I mean I don't I
don't have a proclivity to to do kind of
torture porn it's just in fact I'm very
sensitive about that when I'm a viewer
that you that's not you know uh you you
you you unfairly used my being a human
being against me and uh you didn't you
didn't you know make me provoke my
imagination you are forcing me to feel
something in a in a way that you know I
find distasteful and so I'm pretty
sensitive about it for me as myself as a
viewer and yet there's there's you know
it is a very violent and and scary
situation I I prefer to find that
balance where your mind is filling it in
and so it can be even worse in terms of
its impact on you in the right way where
you're finishing the painting and you
are you are you're you're feeling what
the character I think it's more
one-to-one with what the characters are
feeling because they're feeling kind of
the the ramifications of the violence
and so it's washing over them as they're
thinking about it and same thing with
the audience yeah definitely my mind
goes to probably darker places and the
movies do I did want to ask about
adapting the book also because it feels
like you have not adapted very many
books but recently you seem to be
pursuing that path a little more often
so for all the other authors out there
who might be itching to work with you
what is something you need to see in a
piece of source material to signal to
you this is Cinematic and I need to get
involved in it I mean what a great
question I mean neither of those pieces
were intended to be for me to direct
they were they came one my daughter gave
me as a gift for Father's Day and then
the other one was for me to produce for
some other people and
um so both and maybe both because they
came in that way they weren't they
weren't coming for me as a job for me to
write and direct I could see the Beauty
and the premise But to answer your
question directly both of those pieces
meaning you know oh the The Source
material for old and knock of the cabin
both at the center of them had these
really provocative High concept ideas
that were you know both scary but
emotional so I could you know if they
have both those tendrils that I can keep
the ride going but I can emotionally be
dealing with complex things that's very
exciting for me even your original work
that's what keeps me coming back
speaking of your body of work here one
thing I love is your cameos I would love
to sit here and ask you to rank every
single one of them but we do not have
time so can you give me your top three
cameos that you've ever done in your
films oh my God I would have to really
think about that carefully but I you
know I I don't want to say too much but
I did enjoy these last two because
they're very different versions of how
to be in the movie one is kind of uh I
mean they're both kind of tongue and
cheeky and funny which I really like I
like to make people laugh but one is
more you know really embedded in the
story and one is kind of like you know
an over-the-shoulder kind of thing
um so they both have different purposes
but it's fun to be in the audience when
when that Ripple happens when they're
like you know three quarters of them are
like there he has in there and the one
quarter is like wait who's that Indian
guy and then they're like
and I'm like enough turn and watch The
Story You're Gonna Miss I try not to put
too much important stuff right after I
appear so that because they're all like
I won't spoil it this one's really good
this one's in my top three Ray ready and
then the trio of unbreakable split and
glass I love that that one has it has an
arc like it's a cameo with an arc it's
great
what do we say shouldn't make things up
when we're talking about
can you open the door please
I'll preface this first question by
saying your Chemistry on screen is great
I read a whole lot in the Press notes
about how you two just wanted to hang
out and keep talking together offset too
and I have a quote from M night here he
says at some point I was like there's
nothing else you could say to each other
you've said everything stop talking to
each other
very good night by the way really yeah a
terrible at Impressions I wasn't even
trying to partner on that first what is
something that you found you had in
common that might have surprised you but
then also tell me like the most random
thing that you would talk about just for
fun on the side oh so many Secrets oh so
many Secrets
I had so many in common things we like
we it was kind of spooky discovering
lots of parallels what have you got a
specific one mine was that our
grandfathers were both ministers
yeah yeah which is a weird one kind of a
specific one yeah
that we both were kind of grew up on
farms I did I did at the weekends not
during the week but like my my
grandfather was a farmer so my two
uncles Jonathan grew up on a farm my
grandfather was a farm
there were many many parallels yeah not
just religion and farming other things
too
that's like all I can do all those sexy
Paradise
churchy farmers
that's something
now for your finding this relationship
together Beyond like the script and the
book you got a lot of material to work
with here but what is something that you
would say is maybe purely your own in
terms of figuring out that Dynamic maybe
even something you came up with
backstory wise that we could feel
informing your performances even if we
don't see or hear about it having the
book which is such a good guide and such
a viable and then the way Knight Works
he's religious about his script down to
like commas don't you know everything is
that there isn't a lot of room for
invention from me enough and we were
kind of given everything we needed and
he also the way he makes a film is that
you don't really discover it as an actor
he has seen the entire thing in his head
frame by frame movements where you're
looking what you're doing and so you're
slotting into this like Mastermind
choreography of his and and I think like
you other than just like bringing my own
or calling upon all of my own feelings
and the things that I've experienced in
my are similar to the character then
well I suppose I suppose that really but
I don't know
that it changed the film or anything
just just because I'm I'm curious and
you said that uh Knight is very specific
and and direct with things is there any
kind of direction that he was willing to
give you on this set that maybe
sometimes directors aren't as direct and
specific about that you appreciated and
wish you saw more sets out there he's
super blunt you know when he likes it
and you know when he doesn't like it and
I really appreciate that like he he'll
be like no that's not that's not what I
was getting at and like what Ben said
down to the the word and the comma he
really has
poured his heart and soul and his focus
into making something really specific
before you even arrive on set so so you
know exactly what you're working towards
which is his vision and that I love that
because it's you you
it's it's very clear whether you're
hitting it or not with him so I would
say like his bluntness was probably a
thing that I enjoyed I feel like
bluntness isn't isn't spoken about and
highlighted enough is a good quality to
have in a director yeah at least if that
bluntness is wielded well yes it is yeah
he's extremely kind he never creates any
tension he never raises his voice like I
think those are his own rules he doesn't
want to we're already making a really
intense film I wondered if he might
create tension for the sake of our
experience but he he really doesn't he
wants you to have a good time making it
I was like hearing that so now with Dave
we are talking about this before and I
feel like people often talk about this
he is uh usually boxed in to certain
types of roles so day one of working
with him what was an expectation you had
of him as a performer and then
ultimately how did he surprise you most
by the end of filming I had no
expectation I really I did you did for
me interestingly we had been all
together for two weeks of rehearsal but
Dave was still on Guardians of the
Galaxy he came in even a week and a half
later after that so we shot some of
those scenes pretending that he was
there which was really weird so he was
like this he was the the big presence
that we were missing and then I I think
I thought that he'd be he was the kind
of the most Hollywood element of the
film in my eyes like uh this big action
star but he's so gentle and generous and
and sweet and like he's just a big
tender bear think about big old tender
bear tender bear he's just a big town
I'm not gonna try to imitate you it's
daunting though but you do such a good
night yeah is that I don't can you do a
night impression you can I can okay
[Music]
respect when the camera stopped rolling
yeah
um Jonathan I was reading that this is
your first horror movie so what was it
about making a horror movie that
surprised you most and now did it leave
you with the itch to do more I remember
one day we were shooting shooting and it
was maybe three quarters of the way
through the process saying to you like
this is so intense I I I like drumming
up the terror and emotion again and
again and again and again because
particularly with this movie once it
starts it doesn't stop the first couple
times you're like yeah I got this but
then when you're it's like the end of
the night you're like okay I'm gonna get
tied into this chair again and we're
gonna work up the panic and it was to
keep it at that fever pitch was more
taxing than I anticipated if you do
another horror movie in the future what
particular sub-genre of horror would you
want to tackle most
genre of Horror
I have preferences but I'm okay I
slasher is always my number one I love
all forms of Storytelling Horrors my
genre slasher is my sub genre I will say
that like in Middle School I was
obsessed with screen scream I had the
voice changer
what's your first Jurassic Park yeah
I'd watched surprise I'd watch the
Scream had ice cream force can fight on
the plane on the way over that was our
first conversation we've ever had that
was about watching scream which one the
latest one I think yeah it just makes me
so happy yeah the scream scream seven
will be a couple of scream Queens yeah
hey I mean they're gonna make a seven I
believe it so I would like to see that
happen specific character question for
you Ben because I started to think about
this while watching the movie how do you
think he might have reacted had the
roles been reversed and instead of
having people barge into the cabin he
was one of the people with a vision wow
I agree um that's such a good question
and I think his
overall cynicism about life and we
discover in the film that his job as a
human rights lawyer actually he hasn't
even got that much faith in humanity
because of what he's witnessed and seen
in the cases he's working on and I feel
like the Visions wouldn't have got
through to him I think he just doesn't
believe in that way I think he would
have just dismissed all of it or thought
he was going thought he was losing his
mind over them actually holding any kind
of credence I think
it's just after Dome that was great I
know I'm impressed right now a little
bit of a fun apocalypse question right
now this movie's not fun but I love
Apocalypse movies so let's say you as in
real you you're in the world an
apocalypse happens you can pick two past
co-stars to team up with to give
yourselves the best chance of surviving
who do you each pick definitely Leah
Michelle is one because she's a Survivor
do we have each other you if you want oh
and Ben done Lee and Ben yeah I'm gonna
pick Jonathan and then I'm gonna pick
Vive the apocalypse and we're kind of go
skill based here
um I would choose a friend of mine could
Ruby bandol who was an imperial drama on
the BBC called lock rise to candleford
and she's just great and she looks great
in a bonnet which wouldn't help me in
the apocalypse but Ruby Bento would be
my my apocalypse buddy you love her me
Leah Ruby and you have a great time I
would also watch this movie if you ever
make it okay great um I did want to
highlight talking a little bit about
Kristen here because it this is like one
heck of a first feature for someone and
I always find it interesting that like
when when a kid comes on set it's just
like I don't know there's there's no uh
there's no pressure of history and
everything you've learned so watching
her on set is there anything that you
both saw her do that made you kind of
stop and think like man if only I had
the nerve to try that when I was first
starting out yeah I think that that
touches on a really interesting point
and and there's a difference in the way
that Knight spoke with Kristen than he
did with us he was more even more blunt
with with her I would say and that's
because she hasn't her her own ego isn't
getting in her way yet whereas we've got
like the oh I've certainly have the
fragility of an actor being like Oh God
Andy and he's
he's careful with that whereas her he
just like give it to her no like he
wouldn't dress up the words he would
just and that was I suppose that's
something that that only you can only
have as like a young child actor in that
lack of self-doubt in a way she would
and she was just so like yeah she was so
unfazed by by everything she just went
for it and she became she'd never acted
before and then by the end of it it was
it was such a we were so thrilled to see
that Journey wouldn't we in the comments
that she would make and you know by the
end she was kind of giving us comments
like just say it movie or she'd like she
just really she'd got what the acting
not Knight would hate me saying that but
she she really understood what acting
was by the end
she might be a good apocalypse partner
actually oh my God yeah
what's her greatest skill in the
Apocalypse
probably disarming and Charming everyone
fair enough and I feel like she'd also
be able to like
I feel like she'd be a secret weapon
weapon not that we need it but like a
kind of
super secret spy she's also unflappable
yeah she was the most unflappable person
I was the most flapped and she was the
least
hi there
can I talk to you for a little bit
my first question for you is something
I'm going to borrow from the movie I
want to know what your favorite movie is
well my favorite movie is uh one of the
Harry Potter movies I'm really not sure
which one because I've only I'm working
on the third book and I've only saw his
the first two movies so I'm really not
sure but once I
um see the full like the full
set I'll I'll have to take a bunch of
time and think about it we're gonna have
to revisit that my favorite is Goblet of
Fire the fourth one oh yeah I haven't
seen that one yet you've got a lot to
look forward to what was it like being a
big Harry Potter fan and getting to meet
Rupert well it was it was embarrassing
why was it embarrassing well yeah really
I
I really never met him before and I I
actually didn't um start reading the
Harry Potter when I first met him so
it's kind of cool yeah you meet him and
then you get to see uh you get to see
something that he was part of it was
really special yeah another thing that
is very special is making your first
future film I hope you're very proud of
yourself oh yeah going into filming this
movie what would you say was the most
surprising thing in terms of what it
took to to make a feature film how I
think that they shoot the movie was
really different of how they actually
shot it so I thought that was pretty
surprising because
there was like there was like a blood
track and I thought they were just they
were like I didn't really think about it
but then when I saw it they were
dragging this like white doll and it had
nothing on it and they were dragging
across the floor to make that blood
track special effects makeup will always
wow me it is a real art is there
anything you saw co-star doing this
movie that makes you think like that was
really cool and I want to try that on my
next movie when I see the other movies
and be like me and my mom sometimes
watch how they shoot it but really I've
never seen the blood tracks and stuff I
thought like when you when you like when
you hang up from a string and then like
the string pulls you up it just it's
it's surprising me and I want to try
that sometime I I have a feeling if you
want it there will be stunts in your
future do you watch scary movies
um what's the scariest movie you've ever
seen
it might wind up being this one it's
pretty unnerving
pretty nail biting but I thought that um
one of um Knight's scariest movies was
sixth sense I mean it was like so bloody
it was just it was a it was like a ghost
movie and stuff very special movie it's
a good one the one that scared me the
most was signs the alien movie I've
never seen that one it's another another
M Night movie and it's very very good
when the time comes I recommend it I am
a big believer that we don't tell people
good job nearly enough so can you think
of a time on this set when you saw one
of your co-stars just crush it really go
above and beyond with one of their
scenes and you want to tell them good
job well I would say Ben because he's
he's always so focused on doing this and
like every time that he's on set he's
acting and his emotion like when I don't
know where to begin his emotion like
entirely brings me into the story and
like it it helps me sink in to when
emotions and feelings so I think that
like Ben is always crushing and I really
want to tell him good job
all the time